have you ever been on before no never  the last relationship lasted how many  years growth sexual preference women any  children no and a dog this is my brother  he was here a couple of years ago but he  didn't make it  good morning 44 days left breakfast is  served as you understand from your  brother's experience if you fail to hold  another someone during your stay here  you'll turn into an animal would you  like to dance  winifred Johnny  it's no coincidence of the targets a  shape like single people and not couples  did you catch rabbits catching a rabbit  is difficult thank you very much we have  to be totally synchronized five four  three two have you thought of what  animal you'd like to be if you end up  alone  yes a lobster a lobster is an excellent  choice I can't go much faster these  trousers are too tight I'm sorry  is it okay gave me back oh yes turban a  bookmark Banana Boat  these are callous teaser these are  careless these are careless let me come  here did not ever